der winzer michael lindemann aus lörrach
schaut vor wenigen wochen nach seinen
weinbergen und feldern
die liegen mitten im
deutsch-schweizerischen grenzgebiet
deshalb fährt der nebenerwerbslandwirt
mit seinem 16 jahre alten kombi
zwangsläufig immer wieder über die grüne
grenze
doch an diesem tag steht da plötzlich
der deutsche zoll die herren ich dann
gestoppt und hansjörg seite problem weil
ich nie auto als ware nach deutschland
geführt hat
das eigene auto verzollen michael
lindemann kann es nicht glauben aber die
beamten meinen es ernst
die begründung der
deutsch-schweizerische feldweg sei keine
offizielle zollstraße und weil er bei
seiner tour hier kurz aus deutschland
raus und gut hundert meter weiter wieder
nach deutschland rein fährt müsse er nun
fürs eigene uralte auto zahlen und zwar
494 euro und 40 cent die beamten
eskortieren michael lindemann
höchstpersönlich zum zollamt ich habe es
nicht verstanden warum ich jetzt oder
was für ein fehler dass ich jetzt
begangen habe zwischen der schweiz und
deutschland kann man seit jahren
ungehindert hin und her fahren
kontrollen gibt es so gut wie keine mehr
die löcher verstehen deshalb die welt
nicht mehr der bürokratischer wahnsinn
ja ich kann das überhaupt nicht
verstehen weil wir haben auch
landwirtschaften der fc seine eigene
rede gefahren und hat sicher nichts
gedacht
an sowas schwachsinn doch wer pilze
fingerspitzengefühl ganz einfach beim
hauptzollamt lörrach will man sich vor
der kamera nicht äußern
schriftlich nimmt man die beamten in
schutz
sie gingen deshalb zunächst von
bedingtem vorsatz täuschung bei der
wiedereinführung des pkw aus insofern
handelten sie rechtmäßig aber nachdem
sich der länderspiegel eingeschaltet hat
kommt plötzlich bewegung in die sache
michael lindemann erhält überraschend
post vom zoll und es gibt siehe da eine
amtliche kehrtwende von der absicht die
zollbehörden über das verbringen des pkw
zu täuschen ist in ihrem fall jedoch
nicht auszugehen und die behörde
kündigte an dass michael lindemann das
bezahlte geld zurückbekommt dass jetzt
eine rückerstattung vom zoll kommt
nachdem sie es zdf eingeschaltet hat
genauso unerklärlich wieder strafzettel
offenbar hat die behörde am ende doch
noch gemerkt dass ihr verhalten
gegenüber michael lindemann ganz schön
bürgerfern war